يعني الليله الثالثه على التوالي تتعرض
العاصمه كيف ليها جمال همم الطائرات
المسيره الانتحاريه شاهد في الليله
الماضيه بلغ عدد الطائرات المسيره التي
استهدفت الاراضي الاوكرانيه 51 طائره تم
اسقاطها جميعا او الاغلبيه العظمى منها
طبعا تم اسقاطها في سماء العاصمه كيف تم
تسجيله وصول واحد لطائره وفي الحقيقه ليس
الطائره كامله ولكن تم اصابه الطائره ولكن
جزء منها سقط في منطقه ديزنياسكي وعلى
الطريق ونتيجه هذا السقوط همم اصيب همم
يعني المنزل المجاور من مكان السقوط تضررت
النوافذ الزجاجيه واصيب شاب في التاسعه
عشر من عمره نقل الى المستشفى لتلقي
العلاج ايضا همم لها نصيب من هذه المسيرات
اسقطت سبعه همم مسيرات في سماء همم نيكا
لايف وطبعا تم اصابه هدف واحد من همم
غير محطه محطه كهربائيه وايضا محطه اخرى
حراريه هذه نتيجه الضربات بالمسيرات ولكن
ايضا تم تنفيذ 55 ضربه من راجمات الصواريخ
وانظمه اطلاق الصواريخ المتعدده في
المناطق الجنوبيه وفي المناطق الجنوب جنوب
شرق البلاد وفي شرق البلاد هذه كان نتيجته
ايضا اصابات عديده في منطقه خرسون تحديدا
وتم استهداف المستشفى العمومي في خرسانه
احمد طيب حذيفه في ما يتعلق باقطاع التيار
الكهربائي الملاحظ ايضا ان المسؤوليه
الاخرانيين دائما يعلنون عوده التيار
الكهربائي الى العمل بعد وقت وجيز من
استهداف منشات الطاقه ما هي الاليه التي
يحتبدون عليها لتحقيق ذلك هل هي الاستعانه
بمشاه بديله ام هي سرعه الصيانه لهذه
المنطقه متضرره
نعم احمد طبعا اولا يعني نحنا شهدنا
استقرار في اخر اسبوع لاتيار الكهربائي
بشكل جيد جدا واصبحت القطاعات قليله جدا
في العاصمه كيف والولايات الشماليه
والولايات الغربيه مع سوء الاوضاع في
الولايات الجنوبيه والشرقيه طبعا الاهليه
بسيطه اولا هم يقومون بقطع التيار
الكهربائي وايقاف المحطات بمجرد الاعلان
عن غاره جويه بمجرد ان تنطلق الصواريخ
واعطائرات المسيره الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه
يقول بايقاف هذه المحطات والاغلبيه منها
لان الصيانه همم لهذه المحطات اذا حدث ضرر
وهي تعمل يكون اصعب بكثير ويكون الضرر
اكبر بكثير من اصابتها وهي متوقفه عن
العمل هذه الاولى الثانيه طبعا الفرق همم
من المهندسين ومن العمالهم في حبه
الاستعداد همم اربعه 24 ساعه يصلون بسرعه
الى الموقع ويقومون بعمليات يعني لذلك
يريد التيار
التي حذيفه في شان الميداني اخر والجيش
الروسي اعلن اليوم ايضا انه استهدف في
كياف تقريبا مصنعا لتصنيع الطائرات
المتغيره هل صدر من السلطه الاوكرانيه ما
ينفي او يؤكد هذه المعلومه
نعم في الحقيقه طبعا السلطات الاوكرانيه
تكذب عمليه الاستهداف في كيف لمصانع تعمل
على تطوير المسيرات او او تصنيع المسيرات
وهي تقول ان الاستهداف يتم مناطق مهوله
بالسكان ولكن الدعايه الروسيه تقول انها
استهدفت مثل هذه المصالح